Hi, I'm Kathleen. I'm going to be the instructor in this course, this summer.
I'm really enthusiastic about this udacity class. I've been teaching for about
fifteen years, and most of that time I've been teaching online and I think it's
really an outstanding way to learn things. In a few moments, you'll meet Kai
and Sarah. They developed this course, and you'll being seeing more of them
throughout the semester. First, let's look at some of the things you need to
know in order to be successful. We've worked hard to give you lots of practice,
so you can learn to program. There are lots of in-lesson exercises. See these
blue and gray rectangles? The circles indicate practice questions. They will
turn blue as you progress through the content. Completing these exercises will
prepare you for the problem set. And you need to complete 80% to pass the
class. These exercises take the place of labs that are required in on-campus
classes. You can try exercises as many times as you want. All that matters is
that you learn to do them. No one counts the number of attempts.